Weil, weiß ich nicht, man hat in seinem Leben so viele andere Dinge zu tun. Ich glaube, man hat selten Zeit und bei mir fängt der Schutz gegen den BND eigentlich ein bisschen zu Hause an. Indem ich mich natürlich versuche, meine Daten von mir und von meinem persönlichen Umfeld minimal zu halten. Ja, also ich glaube, es hilft schon, weil ich habe kein Facebook. Ich versuche eigentlich alle Dinge, die ich so betreibe, mal schön getrennt zu halten. Also ich kann jetzt nur von Mitteln reden. Man kann sich auf jeder Plattform mit seinem Facebook anmelden. Man kann sich auf jeder Plattform mit seinem Google Account anmelden. Muss man doch nicht. Man kann sich doch so viele schöne Trash-E-Mails anlegen. Also für jede Dienstleistung, die ich habe, habe ich einen anderen Zugang. Und damit ist es schon mal erheblich schwerer, alle Daten zu fusionieren und mitzubekommen.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, inwieweit du das treibst, aber insofern du nicht für jeden Dienst einen eigenen Rechner benutzt oder zumindest eine eigene virtuelle Maschine auf dem Rechner, halte ich es für relativ wahrscheinlich, dass ein Geheimdienst trotzdem mehr Daten sammeln kann.
Ja natürlich, das ist es.
Ich glaube, die Schwelle...
Aber der eigentliche Punkt ist ja, wenn du dich da vor dem Geheimdienst schützen willst, heißt das ja, du gehst davon aus, dass er doch was macht, was er eigentlich nicht machen soll.
Das wird er tun, ja. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist ja eigentlich die Paradoxie, wenn ich einen Geheimdienst haben möchte, der das Gesetz auf einer gewissen Art und Weise effektiv schützen kann, muss er ja auch in einigen Bereichen neben dem Gesetz oder über dem Gesetz stehen.
Warum?
Ja, weil es schwer ist.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, aber als Argumentation erscheint mir das ein bisschen dünn. Also warum genau, glaubst du, muss der Geheimdienst über dem Gesetz stehen? Also über dem Gesetz ist ja schon eine Formulierung.
Oder sagen wir neben dem Gesetz, oder er muss Befugnisse haben, die die Regelungen des Gesetze oder anders, er hat Befugnisse auch Regeln der Gesetze außer Kraft zu setzen. Interessant ist ja nur einfach interessant, wenn er jetzt Daten sammelt und sammelt und sammelt von mir persönlich. So, der interessante Aspekt kommt dann, was passiert wirklich mit den Daten? Und da muss die Kontrolle hin sein. Sag ich mal, jetzt, er hat jetzt zufällig nebenher herausgefunden, keine Ahnung, weil ich, weiß ich nicht, also man kann nicht mit dem Internet der Dinge...
Micha? Ich würde die Frage gerne mal weitergeben wollen, an die hier anwesenden Studiogäste. Da sagt also jemand, also Geheimdienst kann nicht funktionieren, wenn er nicht neben dem Gesetz steht. Hier haben wir einen Juristen. Was sagt der denn dazu? Also tatsächlich sozusagen, man kann das erst mal als Vermutung anschauen. Geheimdienst macht geheime Dinge, das irgendwie zu regulieren ist vielleicht schwierig. Geht es überhaupt? Also als Konzept kannst du Geheimdienst geben, der juristisch reglementiert ist oder gesetzlich reglementiert ist?
Da bin ich jedenfalls skeptisch, denn jedenfalls gibt es bislang kein Beispiel, wo das funktioniert. Jedenfalls nicht in der Bundesrepublik und für andere Länder will ich da jetzt lieber nicht sprechen. Ich finde aber die These interessant, die der Hörer gerade gemacht hat, Herr Micha, dass ein Geheimdienst über dem Gesetz stehen müsse. Denn ich glaube, das zeigt sehr schön, wie weit wir schon gekommen sind, nicht? Dass also die ständigen Rechtsbrüche durch Geheimdienste, soweit sie der NSI-Untersuchungsausschuss aufgedeckt hat, dazu führen, dass Bürgerinnen und Bürger jetzt quasi schon die Waffen strecken und sagen, ja das muss halt wohl so sein. Also ich finde das ehrlich gesagt schockierend und das ist jedenfalls eine Auffassung, die mit dem Grundgesetz nicht vereinbar ist. Das Grundgesetz geht ganz klar davon aus, dass kein Geheimdienst und auch sonst keine Behörde irgendetwas tun darf, wofür es keine gesetzliche Ermächtigung gibt. Das ist ziemlich einfach, jedenfalls soweit sie dann in Grundrechte eingreift und so ziemlich alles, was eine Behörde tut, greift in irgendeiner Art und Weise in Grundrechte ein, besonders natürlich ein Geheimdienst, einfach weil der ja Informationen sammelt. Das heißt also, sobald es irgendwie um personenbezogene Daten geht, greift er damit in jedenfalls in das Datenschutzgrundrecht ein.
So Micha, es geht also nicht. Hättest du jetzt lieber einen Geheimdienst, oder würdest du das Grundgesetz außer Kraft setzen, oder ändert das vielleicht deine Meinung?
Schwierig. Das Schwierige an einem Geheimdienst ist, wenn er Daten sammelt, hat er sie erst mal gesammelt. Wenn diese Daten, die er von mir persönlich sammelt, bis zu meinem Lebensende in einem dunklen Staufach sind und eigentlich nie irgendeine Relevanz weiter besitzen, dann ist das für mich persönlich in meinem Leben nicht so schlimm.
Naja, aber es wird immer jemanden treffen. Also die Frage ist, mit der Bitte um eine kurze Antwort, hältst du es für sinnvoll, einen Geheimdienst zu haben, der sich über die Gesetze hinweg setzt? Ist erstaunlich, finde ich auch so zu sagen. Das ist auch etwas, was ich vorhin meinte. Man redet ganz viel darüber und es scheint, zumindest in gewissen Kreisen, total einsichtig, dass das eigentlich keine gute Idee ist, aber anscheinend ist der Glaube daran, dass ein Geheimdienst was Sinnvolles anrichtet, ist anscheinend irgendwie da.
Naja, und es kam ja auch das klassische Argument, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen so ein bisschen. Also bei mir wäre es nicht so schlimm, wenn die Daten nur sicher verstaut wären.
Aber das ist schon ein Schritt weiter, als ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Das ist schon eine Ansage. Ja klar, klar, aber es steckt mir drin.
Also ich hab den Hörer nicht so verstanden, dass er sagt, er findet es grundsätzlich gut, dass es Geheimdienste gäbe. Er sagt nur, auch seiner Meinung kann ein Geheimdienst nicht funktionieren, ohne dass der sich über bestimmte Spielregeln hinweg setzt. Und das finde ich ist der spannende Punkt, weil da quasi von dem gegenwärtigen Sein, wo es an dem es so viel Kritik gibt, quasi auf das Rollen geschlossen wird. Also nur weil es heute so läuft, es angeblich immer so sein muss. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist eine schwierige Aufgabe, aber nein, das kann noch lange nicht bedeuten, dass wir aufgeben können, Behörden ans Gesetz zu binden. Denn dann muss man sagen, dann haben wir wirklich so was wie einen Staat im Staat. Unser Parlament und damit letztlich die Bürgerinnen und Bürger steuern über Gesetze. Das ist die Art und Weise, wie wir versuchen, unsere Behörden irgendwie im Griff zu halten und dazu zu bringen, dass sie das tun, was eben die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung will. Und wenn wir diesen Anspruch aufgeben, dass sich Behörden ans Gesetz halten, das ist im Grunde wirklich Anarchie.
So und jetzt soll es tatsächlich so ein Gesetz geben, ein BND-Gesetz. Und bevor wir sagen, dazu kommt was drin, möchte ich mal eigentlich wissen, wo das herkommt. Also wir hatten jetzt neulich gerade diesen Effekt, dass irgendwie so Katastrophenschutzregeln verkündet wurden, wo man irgendwie sich so und so viele Packungen Milch in die Vorratskammer stellen wollte und haben alle gehofft. Und nein, das hat bestimmt mit dem Terror zu tun, aber einfach nur so eine turnusmäßige Aufarbeitung von Katastrophenschutzrichtlinien. Ist es, dass wir ein BND-Gesetz kriegen, auch sozusagen ganz normal und es trifft nur chronologisch zusammen? Oder ist das ein direktes Ergebnis von diesem Untersuchungsausschuss?
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein direktes Ergebnis vom Untersuchungsausschuss. Das letzte BND-Gesetz, das weiß jetzt vielleicht Ulf, das weiß ich gar nicht, aber das ist so richtig steinalt. Und ein paar andere Gesetze, die für die Geheimdienste gelten, also zum Beispiel das G10-Gesetz, was die Kommunikation und die Privatsphäre schützt, ist auch schon ziemlich alt, seit es das letzte Mal reformiert wurde. Es gibt, glaube ich, verschiedene Gründe, warum es das gibt, aber einer ist, würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall, dass im Untersuchungsausschuss rausgekommen ist, dass der BND sich im Grunde seine Gesetze selber gemacht hat. Also da gibt es ein paar uralte Gesetze, die überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Stand der Technik sind, die also beispielsweise sowas wie auch technisch regeln, wie Kommunikationen und Telefonate überwacht werden, und die schlichtweg nicht mehr anwendbar sind, seit Kommunikation digital funktioniert. Ich versuche mal ganz kurz zu machen, nur als ein Beispiel steht in dem G10-Gesetz drin, dass bei bestimmten Formen von Überwachung nur 20 Prozent des Inhaltes eines Kabels, durch das Kommunikation läuft, erfasst werden dürfen. Dieses Gesetz wurde gemacht, als wir noch analog telefoniert haben und man damit 20 Prozent der Telefonate erwischt hat, seit Telefonie auf Internet umgestellt wurde und dann nur noch Pakete durchgehen, macht das keinen Sinn. Weil wenn du 20 Prozent der Pakete hast, hast du hinterher keine vollständige E-Mail, kein vollständiges Telefonat. Und statt dass der BND jetzt irgendwann, als das passiert ist und das war so 2004, 2005 in Deutschland gegangen ist und gesagt hat, das funktioniert so nicht, wir können mit dem Gesetz nicht arbeiten, weil die Technik hat sich weiterentwickelt, hat der BND gesagt, das funktioniert so nicht. Ach, dann machen wir das jetzt einfach anders, weil geht ja nicht. Und haben aber auch niemandem was davon gesagt. Ja, das wusste also auch die aufsichtführende Behörde in dem Fall, das Kanzleramt nicht. Und das ist ein gewissermaßen ein Beispiel von ganz vielen, was der Ausschuss gezeigt hat, dass der BND einfach komplett unkontrolliert macht, was er will, wenn man so will. Und das hat dann, glaube ich, auch die Bundesregierung irgendwann nicht mehr so richtig cool gefunden. Das Gesetz, was wir jetzt haben, müsste eigentlich noch abwarten, bis der Untersuchungsausschuss fertig ist und die Ergebnisse auch tatsächlich da sind. Das ist was, was wir kritisieren, dass die jetzt einfach alleine dahergehen und ein Gesetz machen, was faktisch legalisiert, was jetzt festgestellt wurde, was ja nicht richtig ist, was die machen. Also ich halte das für völlig falsch zu sagen. Das, was die machen, braucht jetzt einfach nur eine gesetzliche Grundlage und dann ist es wieder okay, sondern es müsste eigentlich eingeschränkt werden. Das ist aber, das hat mit Politik zu tun, natürlich unsere große Koalition, die den Geheimdienst aber auch gar nicht wirklich zügeln möchte. Und damit würde ich jetzt mal an die Inhalte dieses Gewinns.
Genau, das klang ja schon so ein bisschen an, dass es der Tenor, wann immer man auf dieses Gesetz trifft, das gesagt wird, na ja, das macht eigentlich nichts, außer alles legalisieren, was jetzt so gerade rauskommt. Kann man es ein bisschen genauer sagen, was da inhaltlich drinsteht oder drinstehen soll, muss man der Zeitung noch sagen?
Der Schwerpunkt dieser geplanten Reform sind Regelungen zur sogenannten Ausland-Fernmeldeaufklärung. Das klingt alles ganz furchtbar kompliziert. Es geht einfach darum, dass Telekommunikation, also z.B. Internetverbindungen im Ausland, abgehört werden, mitgeschnitten werden können durch den BND. Darum geht es. Und wann der BND das können soll oder dürfen soll, steht in diesem Gesetz drin. Und die Regelung ist relativ einfach, die da in Aussicht genommen wird. Der BND soll schlicht und ergreifend alle Netze abhören dürfen, die das Bundeskanzleramt bestimmt hat. Mit anderen Worten, das Bundeskanzleramt sagt, am DECIX in Frankfurt bitte mal mitschneiden und dann darf der BND eben den kompletten Internetverkehr, der durch den DECIX läuft, mitschneiden.
Entschuldigung, jetzt bin ich schon verwirrt, weil gerade ging es doch um Ausland-Ausland-Überwachung. Der DECIX steht in Frankfurt, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, was ja nicht ausland ist. Wie passt das zusammen?
Ja, das wäre insofern ein relativ schlechtes Beispiel, könnte man denken, aber es geht eben um die Telekommunikation, wo die Telekommunikation hinfließt, wo die dann tatsächlich abgegriffen wird, ist erst die zweite Frage, wenn tatsächlich die Telekommunikation von Ausländern im Ausland erfolgt, dann kann der BND damit schneiden. Und da ist eben die Frage, ob der DECIX da reinfällt oder nicht, da streiten sich gerade die Experten darüber. Denn wenn tatsächlich zwei Leute im Ausland kommunizieren und die Leitung aber dummerweise auch über Frankfurt läuft, könnte man auf den Gedanken kommen. Das ist eine der vielen, vielen Unschärfen des Gesetzes. Aber halten wir uns an diesem Beispiel vielleicht nicht zu sehr auf.
Ich möchte nur kurz eine kleine Technik-Erklärung. D-Kix ist, glaube ich, der größte Internet-Knoten sogar. Das Internet kann man sich vorstellen wie eine Ansammlung von Leitungen, die sich auch bündeln zu einem Backbone im Rückgrat des Internets. Das ist sozusagen in Frankfurt. Da gab es auch jetzt eine Klage, glaube ich, dass der Betreiber des G-Kix irgendwie gegen den BND geklagt hat.
Genau, der D-Kix hat 2009 eine Anordnung vom BND bekommen, dass die dort gerne abschnuscheln möchten. Das passiert auch. Und dagegen hat der D-Kix jetzt geklagt. Und das ist auch einer der Punkte des BND-Gesetzes, dass der BND ist im Grunde genommen der Auslandsnachrichtendienst der Bundesregierung Deutschland und der jetzt auch im Inland ermitteln soll. Es soll also mit dem Gesetz auch dazu ermächtigt werden, innerhalb von Deutschland die Kommunikation zu überwachen und auszuwerten.
Aber ich denke nur, um ausländisch zu kommunizieren, da habe ich es schon wieder erst bis jetzt verstanden.
Wobei, man kann ja auch gar nicht so klar differenzieren, ist das jetzt jemand, der kein deutscher Rechts-Träger ist, Grundrechts-Träger ist oder jemand, der sich im Ausland befindet. Wenn ich eine ausländische IP nehme.
Genau, wir haben bei den IP-Paketen einfach das Problem, dass vorne nicht dransteht, wo die herkommen. Also aus welchem Land die IP-Pakete stehen. Die haben jetzt vorne kein header dran, wo dran steht plus für neun, dass man Deutschland zuordnen kann.
Ja, ich finde, wir müssen, bevor wir in solche Details abgleiten, DECICS oder nicht DECICS, deutsche IP, nicht deutsche IP, müssen wir uns zunächst mal klarmachen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Denn das, glaube ich, wird noch nicht in der öffentlichen Diskussion genügend berücksichtigt. Es geht einfach darum, dass ein Schwingerzeig des Bundeskanzleramts reichen soll, damit der BND jede Leitung auf diesem Planeten anzapfen kann, solange darüber nur irgendein Ausländer aus dem Ausland kommuniziert. Und das ist in heutiger Zeit, wo man einfach nicht weiß, wie zum Beispiel IP-Pakete gerautet werden, jede Leitung. Das muss man so deutlich sagen. Der BND soll, wenn es nur das Bundeskanzleramt für richtig hält, jede Leitung abhören können. Und das ist einfach eine sehr, sehr weitreichende Ermächtigung.
Aber ist das schon so auch als Kritik herangetragen worden, einen Gesetzgeber, und gibt es auch eine Erwiderung zu?
Ich wollte gerade zu dem, was Ulf eben gesagt hat, vielleicht noch hinzufügen. Wir hatten eine Anhörung der linken Fraktion, und es hat dann danach noch eine Anhörung im Innenausschuss gegeben. Und bei der einen hat Klaus Landefeld, einer der Betreiber des D-Kicks tatsächlich, die diese Klage jetzt auch sagen, angestrengt, aber eine von diversen Klagen im Übrigen, die es gerade gibt, der hat zu diesem neuen Gesetz gesagt, das fasst das super zusammen, der NSA würde sich freuen, wenn er so ein Gesetz hätte, weil das so weit geht.
Deshalb hatten wir auf unseren Plakaten auch Nein zu deutschen NSA stehen.
Und an diese grundsätzliche Erkenntnis, dass das eine nahezu grenzenlose Lauscherlaubnis ist, die in diesem Gesetz steht, an diese Grunderkenntnis, dann schließen sich Detailprobleme an.
Aber noch mal die Frage, die gerade untergegangen ist, ist das an Kritik schon getragen worden, an den Gesetzgeber? Wenn ihr das da reinschreibt, dann hat das zur Folge, dass jede Leitung davon betroffen ist. Und was ist die Reaktion?
Es gibt Massenhaftkritik und es gibt wirklich schwergewichtige Kritik. Das finde ich wirklich phänomenal an dieser Situation, die wir gerade haben. Also es gibt ein neues Gesetz, was unglaublich weitreichend Überwachungsbefugnisse enthält. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel den ehemaligen Verfassungsrichter Papier, der ganz klar sagt, das geht so nicht, das kann man nicht machen. Der Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages hat gesagt, das ist verfassungswidrig, das kann man so nicht machen. Es hat eine Reihe von, also die Anhörung im Innenausschuss, wo Sachverständige benannt werden von allen Fraktionen im Bundestag. Da haben auch bis auf einen, also alle gesagt, ihr organisiert euch eure Verfassungsklage mit dem Ding selber. Das geht alles überhaupt nicht, also nicht, also sehr viel differenziert, pro und contra und so weiter. Aber im Grunde alle, die gesagt haben, also aus verschiedensten Gründen ist das mit unserer Verfassung nicht vereinbar, was ihr davor habt. Und die Bundesregierung, also die ja auch schon vor drei Jahren übrigens als auch Verfassungsrechter in unserem Untersuchungsausschuss gesagt haben, hier bestimmte Sachen, die ihr dafür grundsätzlich geltend annehmt, nämlich zum Beispiel, dass ihr Ausländer einfach so überwachen dürft und dass für die der G10-Schutz, also Schutz der Kommunikation nicht gilt, das ist auch schon verfassungswidrig. Und dann sagt die Bundesregierung, das sehen wir anders. Das interessiert uns nicht. Also ich war gestern bei einer Veranstaltung, wo der Geheimdienstkoordinator Fritsche auch noch mal zum BND-Gesetz befragt worden ist und genau dazu auch noch mal gelöchert worden ist. Und dann setzt er sich dahin und dann lächelt er und sagt, naja, Sie wissen ja, die Bundesregierung sieht das anders.
Also das ist jetzt der Moment, wo ich persönlich sozusagen wieder ein bisschen resigniert bin. Also weil ich finde schon, man kann sozusagen so was diskutieren. Man kann auch aneinander sein und einfach sagen, es interessiert uns nicht. Das finde ich schon eine harte Nummer in der Demokratie. Aber gut, Ulf, du wolltest noch sagen, es gibt das große Problem. Dann gibt es noch viele kleine Probleme oder kleinere, die davon abgehen.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur auf deinen Einwand zurückkommen, dass es doch jedenfalls nach der Überschrift im Ausland Telekommunikationsüberwachung gehen soll und da gibt es auch bestimmte Regelungen, die zum Beispiel dazu führen sollen, dass Menschen aus europäischen Ländern etwas besser geschützt sind und die sollen auch dazu führen, diese Regelungen, dass Deutsche eigentlich gar nicht in diese Überwachung rein geraten können. Aber dazu hat Sebas ja gerade schon so ein paar Stichworte geliefert. Diese Filtersysteme arbeiten automatisch, das heißt also sie gehen nach ganz formalen Kriterien vor. Wenn ich mit einer Telefonnummer aus Deutschland telefoniere, dann habe ich vielleicht, oder im Ausland aber mit einer deutschen Handynummer zum Beispiel, dann habe ich vielleicht das Glück, dass dann klar ist, okay die Nummer fängt mit plus 4 9 an der deutschen Landeskennung. Mit etwas Glück wird sie dann eben ausgefiltert. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel als Deutscher im Ausland, wo ich normalerweise genauso geschützt wäre, mit einer amerikanischen Handynummer telefoniere, dann erkennen die Computer schon nicht mehr, oh la la, der ist ja Deutscher und schon funktionieren diese Filtersysteme nicht. Und selbst wenn man die irgendwie durch technische Fortentwicklung auf eine sehr hohe Genauigkeit, meinetwegen auch 99, 9 Prozent Treffgenauigkeit bringen würde, dann würde natürlich bei Milliarden von abgehörten Verbindungen immer noch jeden Tag eine Vielzahl von Verbindungen abgehört, die eigentlich nicht abgehört werden darf. Und das ist genau das Problem bei diesem Gesetz. Es ist eine uferlose Überwachung, die dem BND erlaubt wird. Und die Filterverfahren, das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel gewesen, diese Filterverfahren oder die sonstigen Grenzen, die in diesem Gesetz formal drinstehen, die erstmal den Eindruck erwecken, als wenn sie die Überwachungstätigkeit einschränken, die sind alle Gummiparagrafen. Das heißt, da gibt es überhaupt keine Begrenzung, die tatsächlich wirksam sind. Es gibt auch keine parlamentarische Kontrolle zum Beispiel. Da wird ein neues Geheimgremium geschaffen, in Karlsruhe angesiedelt, beim Bundesgerichtshof, wo zwei Bundesrichter und ein Mitarbeiter des Generalbundesanwalts sitzen und die dann im Nachhinein informiert werden, müssen nur welche Netze abgehört werden, nicht welche Suchbegriffe verwendet werden, nicht welche Personen gegebenenfalls. Das ist also ein Gesetz, das quasi auf der Stirn trägt. Wir wollen, dass der BND so gut wie alles darf und wir haben dann einfach nur so ein wenig rechtsstaatlichen Zuckerguss darüber gegossen. Und das ist wirklich in dieser Maßlosigkeit aus meiner Sicht beispiellos.
Sie sehen mich ein bisschen fassungslos. Ich will noch kurz nachfragen, geht es im Gesetz wirklich nur darum, also quasi um die Abhörung dieser Kommunikation? Also weil diese ganze Nummer mit den Drohnen kommt ja dann da gar nicht vor.
Na es gibt natürlich Regelungen zum Austausch mit anderen Staaten, auch die sind extrem weit gefasst. Also da gibt es dann zwar, ich will das jetzt mal kurz zusammenfassen, da gibt es dann die Voraussetzung, dass man sich auf so eine Art Spielregeln einigen muss. Man kann also jetzt nicht völlig frei Daten an einen ausländischen Dienst liefern, sondern man muss mit dem gewissen Terms bestimmte Spielregeln vorher aushandeln. Aber auch das sind alles Regelungen, die letzten Endes keine ernsthafte Begrenzung darstellen. Das ist sehr interessant, wenn man da mal ein bisschen in die Details schaut, dann sieht man immer, das ist geschrieben mit dem Anspruch im Kopf, dass alles gehen muss. Es muss sich so lesen, als wäre es eine rechtsstaatliche Kontrolle in Wirklichkeit, aber muss alles möglich sein. Und das finde ich wie gesagt aus der rechtsstaatlichen demokratischen Perspektive hochgradig problematisch. Darüber, finde ich, müsste auch viel mehr gesprochen werden. Wollen wir eine Behörde, die so gut wie alles darf, wenn es um Telekommunikationsüberwachung geht?
Die große Überraschung bei der Sitzung im Innenausschuss war ja, dass ausgerechnet der Ex-Chef des BND auch gesagt hat, dass die Beschneidung parlamentarischer Kontrollbefugnisse wirklich ein Fehler ist. Und ja, wenn wir uns noch mal das große Bild angucken, dass hier jetzt offensichtlich ein verfassungswidriges Gesetz durchgebracht werden soll, dann sehen wir, dass es in ganz vielen Bereichen im Bereich Überwachung immer wieder gemacht wird. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht wirklich ein Skandal, dass man sich als Bundesregierung hinstellt und genau weiß, das Bundesverfassungsgericht wird dieses Gesetz beschneiden, zurechtstutzen und dann gucken wir mal, was die Maximalversion ist, was wir da durchkriegen. Und aus meiner Sicht ist es wirklich, also wie kann man sich als Politiker hinstellen, als Justizminister beispielsweise und sagen, ich verantworte ein Gesetz, von dem ich schon weiß, dass es vom Verfassungsgericht zurückgepfiffen wird. Und da kann ich noch mal daran erinnern, dass diese These, dass Leute sich nicht für Überwachung interessieren, aus meiner Sicht nicht stimmt. Denn eine der größten Massenverfassungsbeschwerden in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland war die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Naja, aber die ist halt auch schon wieder eine ganze Weile her und seitdem hat sich viel getan.
Es gibt ja eine zweite.
Zu der man sozusagen, zu der man, aber naja, aber halt nicht mehr in dieser Masse halt.
Doch es gab eine Massenverfassungsbeschwerde von Digitalcourage und anderen Unterstützern, die auch 10.000 Unterstützer hatte.
Naja, aber sozusagen jetzt gibt es halt das BND-Gesetz und da schreit halt noch keiner und das ist halt schon, das finde ich schon bedenklich.
Genau, ich glaube, bis es dann zu einer Verfassungsklage kommt, das wird ja noch ziemlich lange dauern und bis dahin ist der Frost schon ganz schön weichgekocht, würde ich sagen. Also dann läuft dieses Gesetz schon eine ganze Weile und dann ist es glaube ich schwer, das nochmal wieder auf Null zurückzudrehen, selbst wenn sich die politische Situation dahin wandeln würde. Weswegen ich mich gerade nochmal gemeldet habe, war, ich habe auch erst gestutzt, als Schindler in der Innenausschussanhörung gesagt hat, also dass selbst er findet, dass da mehr parlamentarische Kontrolle hin muss, als im Gesetz steht. Ja, klar, aber Schindler ist auch als BND-Präsident abgesetzt worden und der findet, dass das Kanzleramt ihn als Bauernopfer genommen hat dafür, dass sie selber sich aus der Verantwortung gestohlen haben, weil das Kanzleramt nämlich gar nicht wissen wollte, was der BND eigentlich macht und der findet und das hat auch Fritzsche gestern Abend nochmal gesagt, das BND-Gesetz, das wird gemacht für die BND-Mitarbeiter, um die besser zu schützen, damit die nicht den Ärger abkriegen, wenn irgendwann rauskommt, was die alles machen, wenn das vorher schon bekannt ist, dann ist das Kanzleramt und die Bundesregierung schuld, aber nicht der BND und das möchte der ehemalige BND-Präsident gerne.
Ist das eine gute Idee? Also ich meine, da könnte man jetzt auch sagen, okay, so kann man es vielleicht wirklich machen. Der Geheimdienst zu sagen, macht erst mal, aber die schuld muss dann die Politik tragen.
Ich persönlich finde beides nicht richtig, weil ich gerne nicht möchte, dass die das machen und dass die nicht so eine Überwachungsbefugnisse haben, aus genau den Gründen, die Ulf ja schon genannt hat. Je schlimmer die Überwachungsgesellschaft ist, die du hast, und das haben wir ja jetzt schon, die Chilling-Effekte sind enorm. Also die wahrgenommene, irgendwie in allen Geräten steckende Dauerüberwachung, die wir haben, die führt dazu, dass Menschen sich im Grunde nicht mehr trauen, irgendwo aufzuschreiben oder irgendwo auszusprechen, was sie wirklich denken. Und damit ist die Meinungsfreiheit massiv angegriffen. Wenn du permanent das Gefühl hast, du wirst beobachtet irgendwie und du weißt gar nicht woher, dann überlegst du dir ganz genau, wie und wo und was du äußerst. Und diesen Freiraum, den wir aber als Grundlage von Meinungsfreiheit brauchen, der ist, finde ich, dessen Einschränkung ist das tatsächliche Problem, warum wir so ein BND-Gesetz nicht haben dürfen.
Und die technische Hürde, sich vor Überwachung zu schützen, wird ja konstant, die Latte wird immer konstant wieder eine Latte höher gelegt. Also wenn ich mich an unseren Anrufer eben erinnere, ich finde es ja grundsätzlich gut, wenn man sich Gedanken macht, aber ich denke dann immer so, naja, was wird meine Oma machen? Die ist jetzt keine IT-Expertin gewesen. Und selbst wenn ich verschlüssele heute, ist ja die Frage, wird irgendwann ein Gesetz durchkommen, was Verschlüsselung in Deutschland rechtlich verbietet, dass ich mich strafbar mache, wenn ich Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen nutze, ohne Bektor. Und diese Diskussion poppt ja immer wieder alle paar Jahre auf. Und wenn wir jetzt konstant, sag ich mal, der Frosch im Wasser ist und das Wasser erwärmt sich und wir gewöhnen uns langsam daran, dann macht es mir wirklich Sorge, dass so etwas irgendwann durchkommt. Und dann haben wir alle die Konsequenzen. Selbst wenn ich sage, ich hab nichts zu verbergen und ich werde nicht in den Radar eines BND oder eines Verfassungsschutzes oder der NSA geraten, meine Daten werden erst mal trotzdem abgegriffen. Und naja, ich lese ja Zeitungen als normaler Bürger. Ich nehme ja an der Politik in diesem Land teil. Und wenn ich keine Journalisten mehr habe, die frei berichten können, frei recherchieren können, wenn ich keine Politiker mehr habe, die frei agieren können, keine Aktivisten, die Protest organisieren, dann ist mein, also dann leben wir in einer verzerrten Demokratie, die aus meiner Sicht auch keine Demokratie mehr ist.
Gerade auf dieses letzte Stichwort Journalisten, die überwacht werden, wollte ich noch ganz kurz eingehen, einfach weil ich da ein konkretes Beispiel dazu bringen kann. Ich kenne ja ganz gut Markus Becke, Andre Meister, die den meisten Hörern wahrscheinlich noch bekannt sind, spätestens seit der Netzpolitik-Affäre im vergangenen Sommer. Und als diese Ermittlungen liefen, wo der Generalbundesanwalt Ermittlungen geführt hat wegen des Verdachts des Landesverrats. Da haben die sich natürlich große Gedanken gemacht, ob sie jetzt überwacht werden. Und ich habe da so einen gewissen Eindruck bekommen, was das eigentlich bedeutet, als Journalist zu arbeiten in der Befürchtung, dass da jetzt gerade irgendeinen Geheimdienst oder irgendeine Strafverfolgungsbehörde in der Leitung hängt bei jedem Telefongespräch. Oder dass die eben auch an der Internetleitung hängen. Das ist einfach eine extrem schwierige Arbeit, weil man eben selbst, wenn man sich mit Technik gut auskennt, wie eben Markus und Andre, eben extrem konzentriert vorgehen muss, um sich da überhaupt noch schützen zu können und vor allem auch um Quellen schützen zu können. Und ich denke, wir alle wissen, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten ihre Arbeit einfach nicht tun können, ohne Informationen. Das heißt, sie sind darauf angewiesen, dass Menschen wissen, dass sie sich sicher fühlen können, wenn sie sich an Journalisten wenden. Und das sichere Wissen ist einfach nicht mehr da, wenn zum Beispiel eben der BND im Prinzip jedes Byte, das durch das Internet fließt, erst mal mitschneidet. Wie gesagt, es gibt da bestimmte Filterregeln. Sie können jetzt nicht alles 100 Prozent auf ihre Festplatte legen, aber wer weiß denn schon, welche Suchbegriffe die jetzt verwenden.
Und trotzdem ist es so, es gibt immer noch das Argument, dass gesagt wird, ja, aber die Überwachung, also ich hab jetzt gerade ein konkretes Beispiel bekommen für eine Berufsgruppe, wo das natürlich relevant ist. Aber es gibt immer noch heute die sagen, na ja, aber man merkt es halt selber nicht. Robert ist einer von denen jetzt am Telefon. Hallo, guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend. Grüß Gott.
Du sagst, man merkt Überwachung nicht und deswegen wehrt sich keiner.
Genau, Überwachung ist total subtil. Im Endeffekt kannst du nichts sehen. Du würdest die Überwachung vielleicht wahrnehmen, wenn deine Daten irgendwo draußen wieder auftauchen. Das ist aber nicht der Fall. Insofern wirst du dich auch nicht gegen Überwachung wehren, weil du sie eben nicht bemerkst.
Aber das widerspricht genau dem, was hier gerade gesagt wurde. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo tatsächlich selber davon ausgehen muss, dass du überwacht wirst, dass es halt doch dann einen Effekt hat.
Genau, aber wer wehrt sich denn noch oder wer kann sich denn noch wehren? Technisch kann sich sowieso keiner mehr wehren. Überwachung ist, wie man schon sagte in der Runde, ist in jedem Gerät drin. Überwachung läuft nicht nur in deinem Rechner, sondern auch außerhalb deines Rechners. Also sobald die Daten irgendwo auf die Leitung gehen, werden sie überwacht. Verschlüsselung, gibt es überhaupt noch Verschlüsselung? Also bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher. Die NSA hatte 2013 Budget von 10 Milliarden Dollar.
Also ich will mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber ich glaube, die meisten Experten gehen davon aus, dass richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung verschlüsselt.
Ja, richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung, aber es wird ja alles dafür getan, dass richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung gar nicht erst stattfindet. Ich sag mal, wie war das jetzt mit Symantec und Blue Code? Das ist so ein Bereich, technisch ist der jetzt, aber Symantec hat eben Zertifikate oder RU-Zertifikate an Blue Code gegeben. Blue Code ist so eine...
Robert, Robert, das sind zu viele Details. Die Frage ist ja, wer ist du dich, wer ist du dich, Robert? Wer ist du dich gegen die Überwachung?
Kann ich nicht mehr. Ich bin zwar nicht einer von dieser Post-Privacy-Gesellschaft, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man...
Aber du könntest zum Beispiel auf die Straße gehen.
Ich könnte auf die Straße gehen, genau. Aber würde die Überwachung damit abgestellt? Die Überwachung wird nicht mehr abgestellt. Die Überwachung funktioniert einwandfrei. Die Überwachung läuft. Warum sollte ich als Gesetzgeber... Ich gebe doch nur das zu, was ich nur zugeben kann oder muss, sagen wir mal so. Warum sollte ich Überwachung abstellen? Welchen Vorteil hat für mich das?
Aber dann gehst du davon aus, dass wir ihr den Glauben an alles Demokratische aufgeben können und du in einer Welt, die du nicht mehr ändern kannst?
Im digitalen Bereich definitiv. Also ich hab mir letztens noch Zero Days angeguckt, den Film, ich weiß nicht, ob den jemand gesehen hat, über Stuxnetz. Ich gucke, ich hab damals den Film mit Robert Redford gesehen, der hieß Nekas, die Lautlosen, schon da ging es um Verschlüsselung. Schon da war mir im Grunde genommen klar, dass wir das gar nicht mehr so in der Hand haben und dass die NSA zu einem Instrument geworden ist, was man nicht mehr kontrollieren kann. Und wenn wir nicht können, aus rein budgettechnischen Gründen, wenn Deutschland nicht die Mittel hat, naja, dann wird halt im Ausland nachgefragt.
Okay, ein etwas düsterer Ausblick und vor allen Dingen also sehr hoffnungslos. Teilst du das, Anne?
Ich kann das Gefühl total gut verstehen und manchmal habe ich das auch und denke, da ist einfach nichts mehr zu machen. Und irgendwann ist mir dann aufgegangen, dass wir so eine Situation schon mal hatten. Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her und das wissen vielleicht nicht mehr alle aus eigenem Erleben, aber die Bewegung gegen Atomkraft, die hatte ganz ganz ähnliche Probleme. Atomkraft ist was, was man nicht spürt, was eine technische Entwicklung ist, der man scheinbar überhaupt nicht mehr aus dem Weg gehen konnte, weil Kohle ist irgendwann alle und Öl haben wir auch nicht. Also Atomkraft muss einfach sein. Als ich Kind war, da gab es diese Argumente tatsächlich noch, da gab es diese Auseinandersetzungen. Da hieß es ja, wollt ihr denn wieder mit Kerzen beleuchten? Es gibt einfach überhaupt keine Alternative dazu. Und die Bewegung war klein dagegen und sie hat viele Jahrzehnte gebraucht, aber es war tatsächlich möglich, dann doch sich dagegen zu wehren. Und ich glaube, wir müssen uns auf einen langen Kampf einrichten, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das hoffnungslos ist. Ich glaube, auch wir haben keine Alternative, als uns dagegen zu wehren, weil ich glaube, die Welt, wie sie wird, wenn wir in dieser totalen potenzierten Ohrwälschen-Überwachungs-Gewellschaft leben, die ist einfach nicht mehr lebenswert. Das können wir nicht hinnehmen.
Okay, darüber sprechen wir gleich. Wir müssen eine kurze Pause machen, weil jetzt wieder Nachrichtenzeit ist. Und danach machen wir mal kleine Zukunftsaussichten, vielleicht sowohl die gute als auch die schlechte Variante.
Ihr habt euch schon immer gefragt, wofür das K bei Contra K steht. Na, das steht aktuell für K. Keiner kann künftig Contra K Columbia Konzertkarten kaufen. Komplettes Kontingent. Kaufversauft. Kacke. Aber zum Glück gibt's ja noch das große rote F.
Denn Fritz hat sie für euch.
Die letzten Tickets fürs ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert von Contra K. Freitag, 4. November. Live in der Kolumbiale. Schon komplett ausverkauft. Aber wenn ihr trotzdem noch dabei sein wollt, fritz.de slash Contra K. Die letzten Tickets fürs ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert von Contra K.
Die Berliner SPD ist bereit, mit Linken und Grünen über eine gemeinsame Koalition zu verhandeln. Der Landesvorstand nahm am Abend eine entsprechende Empfehlung von Regierungschef Müller an. Nach den Sondierungsgesprächen hatte Müller schon gesagt, dass es viele Gemeinsamkeiten gebe. Bei der Finanz- und Energiepolitik gebe es aber noch Gesprächsbedarf. Es wäre das erste rot-rot-grüne Bündnis unter Führung der SPD in Deutschland. In Berlin-Lichtenberg soll der Leiter eines Supermarktes einen Ladendieb so schwer geschlagen haben, dass er gestorben ist. Von der Polizei heißt es, der Laden im Bahnhof Lichtenberg sei schon am Dienstag geschlossen und durchsucht worden. Gegen den Fihalleiter wurde Haftbefehl erlassen. Nach den bisherigen Ermittlungen war der Ladendieb vor zwei Wochen in dem Lebensmittelmarkt erwischt worden. Anstatt ihn der Polizei zu übergeben, soll er von dem Fihalleiter schwer misshandelt worden sein. Erst zwei Tage später habe der Mann einen Arzt aufgesucht, der ihn sofort ins Krankenhaus geschickt habe. Dort sei er dann verstorben. Die USA haben Russland damit gedroht, die Gespräche über eine Waffenruhe in Syrien abzubrechen. US-Außenminister Kerry drohte Russland damit, die Gespräche wegen der anhaltenden schweren Kämpfe um Aleppo zu beenden. Kremelsprecher Pieskov sagte aber, Russland wolle die Luftangriffe auf Aleppo fortsetzen. Inzwischen hat Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier Russland aufgefordert, sich mit den USA wenigstens auf eine vorübergehende Feuerpause zu einigen. Die täglichen Bombenangriffe müssten endlich aufhören. Schalke 04 hat in der Europa League Österreichs Meister RB Salzburg mit 3 zu 1 besiegt. Damit hat Schalke den 2. Sieg im 2. Gruppenspiel eingefahren. Fußball-Bundesligist Mainz 05 feierte seinen 1. Sieg in der Europa League. Die Mainzer gewannen in Baku beim FK Käbele mit 3 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn gerade 20 Grad und in Schöneberg noch 23, in Angermünde und Neuropin 20, in Potsdam und Frankfurt-Oder 21 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es bewölkt und zwischendurch kann es auch einzelne Schauer geben. Es kühlt noch auf bis zu 12 Grad ab. Morgen bleibt es überwiegend grau und regnerisch bei Höchstwerten um die 22 Grad. Vorsicht auf der A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden. In Höhe der Raststätte Rüblingsheide steht ein kaputtes Auto auf der Beschleunigungsspur. Zum Stadtverkehr Berlin in Mitte ist die Strahlauer Straße immer noch wegen eines Wasserrohrbruchs zwischen Mühendamm und Janowitzbrücke in Richtung Holzmarktstraße gesperrt. Bei der S-Bahn gibt es Probleme. Auch heute Nacht ist die Strecke zwischen Friedrichstraße und Charlottenburg gesperrt. Zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologischer Garten fahren Busse im 20-Minuten-Takt. Probleme gibt es auch bei der U-Bahnlinie 7. Bis Ende November ist die Strecke zwischen Zwickauer Damm und Rudow unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahren dort Busse. Wo ihr durchkommt, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal Fritz.de slash Tipps.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo immer noch zu Gast sind Sebas, Ulf Bohmeyer, Anne Roth und Katharina Nocun. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal. Und wir haben jetzt eine halbe Stunde schon geredet über den NSL Untersuchungsausschuss, über den BND, über das neue BND Gesetz. Und wenn ich die letzten 90 Minuten mal zusammenfassen möchte, könnte ich sagen, es ist alles fürchterlich, weil der NSL Untersuchungsausschuss, das ist alles sehr zäh und wird auch viel geheim bleiben. Das BND-Gesetz führt im Prinzip dazu, dass der BND in Zukunft eigentlich alles überwachen darf, was es so gibt und es demonstriert niemand. Oder zu wenig. Und ich würde die letzte halbe Stunde tatsächlich gerne noch dazu nutzen, um mal zu gucken in die Zukunft, wie das werden kann. Ich würde da gerne mal in die Nachbarländer gucken. Und zwar, also was kann oder wie ist es denn, wenn so Gesetze erst mal in Kraft treten, die eine Überwachung überlauben. Und das muss man so ein bisschen vergleichen, der nicht so ganz stimmt. In Frankreich gibt es nämlich seit Ende 2015 den Ausnahmezustand und der hat zumindest abstrakt was damit zu tun. Wer von euch hat sich noch mal anguckt, was genau da alles drin steckt?
Ja, ich bin sicher kein Experte für französisches Recht. Ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch das Internet konsultiert und das hat zu dem Ergebnis geführt, dass der Etat d'urgence, der Ausnahmezustand in Frankreich, zunächst mal vom Präsidenten ausgerufen werden kann, muss dann aber durch ein Gesetz bestätigt werden und der ermöglicht eine ganze Fülle von Überwachungsmaßnahmen, aber auch anderen Einschränkungen von Bürgerrechten. Zum Beispiel können Ausgangssperren verhängt werden, die Bewegungsfreiheit kann eingeschränkt werden, Wohnungsdurchsuchungen ohne richterlichen Beschluss sind möglich oder auch Hausarreste für Menschen, also quasi Haft bei sich daheim, für Menschen, deren Aktivität als gefährlich für die Sicherheit und die öffentliche Ordnung angesehen wird. Das heißt also, das klingt auch sehr nach einem Gummi-Paragrafen und zugleich nach sehr weitreichenden Einschränkungen der klassischen bürgerlichen Freiheitsrechte.
Und es ist ja immer so mit so Sicherheitsgesetzen heißt immer, das ist ja alles gegen den Terror und dass man das auch für andere Sachen verwenden kann. Gibt es eine konkrete Geschichte Katharina?
Ja genau, und zwar gab es einen Global March on Climate, der fand in ganz Europa in unterschiedlichen Städten am selben Tag statt und ich war da näher dran, weil ein Kollege von mir so in der Organisation in Berlin mitgemischt hat. Und eigentlich war so ein Event in Paris geplant, was auch Sinn macht, da die Konferenz, wo über das Klima debattiert wurde, auch in Paris stattfand. Diese Demonstration wurde aber verboten, auch mit Hilfe dieser Notstandsgesetze. Und Aktivisten, die in dem Umfeld tätig waren oder die dafür mobilisiert haben, haben eben diese Ausgangssperren bekommen. Das heißt, Leute, die ganz bestimmt nichts mit Terrorismus zu tun haben, thematisch was vollkommen anderes, die einfach nur friedlich demonstrieren wollten, die konnten es dann nicht. Was ich aber ganz schön fand, ist, dass es trotzdem dann einen Protest gab. Und zwar haben die Veranstalter aus Protestern ganz viele Schuhe aufgestellt von Leuten, die zu der Demo gekommen wären auf dem Platz. Das heißt, es sind einfach Leute vorbeigekommen, haben ihre Schuhe dort abgestellt, dann quasi nach der Demo wieder abgeholt. Und um klarzumachen, das geht so nicht.
Aber ich würde persönlich sagen wollen, dass das Gesetz missbraucht worden ist. Weil gegen Klimawandel ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Terror. Und Ausnahmezustand hat ja auch so was temporäres eigentlich. Aber das gibt es jetzt seit ein paar Monaten und es ist auch sozusagen nicht so abzusehen, wann das wieder eingestellt wird. Das finde ich auch spannend. Und das zeigt es halt sehr schön, dass so eine Gesetze, die dem Staat viel Macht geben, dann auch gekommen sind, um zu bleiben. Das ist zumindest so mein Eindruck.
Also das Gesetz ist ja eingesetzt worden im November 2015 und erst mal bis Januar 2017 beschränkt in Frankreich. Nur die Frage, die sich stellen wird, wird man das Gesetz wieder zurücknehmen oder wird man es verlängern? Weil ich möchte ja auch niemand die Verantwortung übernehmen, wenn dann etwas passiert, wenn das Gesetz zurückgenommen worden ist in seiner jetzigen Form. Na ja, man hat ja jetzt alle Möglichkeiten, um gegen den Terror anzugehen und sich dagegen zu schützen. Und wenn man jetzt dieses Mittel, was man in Kraft gesetzt hat, wieder zurücknimmt und dann etwas passiert, muss man da natürlich auch die politischen Konsequenzen ziehen. Und die möchte aktuell niemand tragen.
Das heißt, Überwachungsgesetze werden nicht zurückgenommen, weil kein Politiker das Gesicht verlieren will?
Na, weil auch vielleicht nicht genügend Widerstand aus der Bevölkerung kommt.
Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung kann man ja ganz konkret sagen, dass Sigmar Gabriel offen kommuniziert hat, er möchte dieses Gesetz durchbringen, obwohl der Justizminister Heiko Maas ja auch eigentlich dagegen war oder zumindest öffentlich gesagt hat, er möchte das auch nach den Anschlägen in Paris nicht durchdrücken, weil er eben gesagt hat, na ja, wenn ein Terroranschlag hier in Deutschland stattfinden sollte, dann wird sofort der Finger auf die SPD fallen. Warum habt ihr das denn nicht gemacht? Weil mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung kann ja bekanntlich alles verhindert werden, was ja auch so nicht stimmt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn ich das nochmal kurz erläutern würde.
Das war ironisch gemeint. Es ist halt immer so die Standardargumentation, ja, mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten wir das verhindern können, obwohl wir ja ganz klar sehen, dass beispielsweise die Attentate in Paris nicht mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung verhindert werden konnten. Und gerade, wenn ich weiß, dass so ein Gesetz in Kraft tritt, oder in Kraft ist in einem Land, das eben speichern, mit wem ich wann telefoniere, wäre ich ja dumm, sag ich mal, mein eigenes Handy zu nutzen, um darüber einen eventuellen Anschlag zu planen.
Und deswegen müssen wir Verschlüsselung verbieten und beim Handykauf immer den Personalausweis vorlegen lassen.
Ja, also diese Mehr von der totalen Sicherheit ist aus meiner Sicht eben eine ganz fatale. Aus meiner Sicht müssen wir eben irgendwo akzeptieren, dass es eine totale Sicherheit nicht gibt. Ich habe eben, also ich habe vor einigen Monaten war ich in einer Podiumsdiskussion, da hat jemand etwas ganz Kluges aus dem Publikum gesagt. Und zwar hatte der sich angeschaut, wie viele Leute eigentlich pro Jahr von aus dem Fenster geschmissenen Fernsehern tödlich verletzt werden. Und das sind gar nicht so wenige. Und wenn wir uns einfach anschauen, es gibt immer ein Risiko und wir werden es nicht total verhindern können. Wenn wir aber versuchen, das Risiko auf Null zu drücken, a. werden wir es nicht schaffen und b. landen wir dann einfach in einem totalitären Start. Und dann, würde ich sagen, ist der größte Anschlag gegen die Demokratie geglückt. Dann haben wir nämlich unsere freiheitlichen Werte von ganz alleine aufgegeben.
Es gibt tatsächlich aber Leute, die denken, Überwachung hat auch was Gutes. Und einer davon hat angerufen, nämlich der Nils aus Lichterfeld. Hallo und guten Abend. Was genau soll denn Überwachung Gutes haben?
Für mich, also ich rede jetzt mal ausschließlich über die Geheimdienste und nicht über WhatsApp, Facebook, Google, Microsoft und Co. Ich denke, wenn mehr publik gemacht werden würde, welche Vorteile oder Ermittlungsergebnisse auch eine Überwachung hat, dann wäre ein Großteil der Bevölkerung auch bereit, gewisse Daten preiszugeben.
Aber was für konkrete Vorteile meinst du denn?
Ich meine jetzt nicht nur Terrorismus, ob links oder rechts, das ist völlig egal, sondern einfach Verbrechen aufgedeckt werden anhand von Überwachung.
Ja, aber welche Verbrechen sind das? Also ich habe jetzt...
Eben, das wissen wir ja nicht.
Ach warte, du behauptest also sagen, eigentlich hilft Überwachung schon gegen Verbrechensaufklärung, und das wird uns aber nicht gesagt. Das halte ich also mit Verlauf sehr weit hergeholt.
Also Teile der Antwort würden uns verunsichern.
Also ganz kurz, also A gibt es sozusagen, was die Vorwärtssatenspeicherung angeht, immer wieder Untersuchungen in Ländern, wo es die Vorwärtssatenspeicherung gibt, dass das nichts hilft. Und B, also um die... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das nachvollziehen sollte, weil die Politik, der wird ja immer gesagt, beweist doch mal bitte, dass diese ganze Überwachung funktioniert. Und dann sagt sie, ja tut sie ja, wir würden es euch auch konkret zeigen, aber das geht halt nicht so genau. Aus welcher Motivation sollte denn das verschwiegen werden?
Bei für mich einfachen Geheimdienst, ob das der BND ist oder die NSA oder in anderen Ländern XYZ, wir wissen auf der einen Seite nicht wirklich, was sie tun, oder wir vermuten und unterstellen einfach mal, sie tun alles, nur nichts Gutes. Es gibt immer zwei Seiten, also ich glaube, es gibt einige Fälle, die Spitze des Eisberges. Wir erfahren doch nicht alles, was wirklich passiert.
Nils, um das abzukürzen und sagen, du glaubst, das versuche ich gerade noch mal zu fragen, du glaubst also, durch Überwachung werden Verbrechen aufgeklärt und deswegen findest du Überwachung gut?
Das heißt nicht, dass ich Überwachung gut finde, aber mir wird das alles ein bisschen zu negativ dargestellt. Klar kann man auf der einen Seite sagen, wer nichts zu verbergen hat, der soll sich nicht aufregen. Ich bin in so einer Generation, 78, ich wäre 40. Ja, ich mach's.
Ich versuche das noch mal genauer zu vergründen. Also das finde ich jetzt einen natürlich unspannenden Punkt, weil wie kann man denn als Überwachungsgegner dagegen argumentieren, wenn jemand sagt, na ja, aber uns wird ja sozusagen verheimlicht, was das für gute Seiten hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man da anfangen soll.
Naja, also da kann ich vielleicht mal einwerfen als Argument. Bei ganz konkreten Anschlägen in Brüssel beispielsweise oder auch in Frankreich ist ja im Nachhinein rausgekommen, dass der Geheimdienst tatsächlich Information hatte, weil man sich allerdings so auf Massenüberwachungsinstrumente konzentriert hat, hat man quasi die Nadel im Heuhoffen nicht mehr gefunden.
Was Dieter sagt, es gibt...
Das ist aus meiner Sicht eben die Unterscheidung, die man treffen muss. Also zielgerichtete Ermittlungen, denke ich, klar, sollte man auf jeden Fall tun. Und ich denke, sie ist auch... Ich weiß, dass sie tatsächlich effektiver ist als Massenüberwachung, die erst mal alle Bürger einschließt. Und diese Unterscheidung an Effektivität, die wird in der Politik aus meiner Sicht gar nicht gerade diskutiert. Und das ist der Fehler.
Das ist, glaube ich, aber eine kategoriale Unterscheidung, die ganz wichtig ist. Denn ich würde zum Beispiel niemand sagen, wir brauchen überhaupt gar keine Überwachung, um mal ein Beispiel zu bilden. Wenn man jetzt tatsächlich jemanden im Verdacht hat, er könnte einen anderen Menschen umgebracht haben. Und deswegen werden gegen ihn strafrechtliche Ermittlungen geführt. Und der hat eine Freundin. Und man hofft halt einfach, dass er möglicherweise am Telefon irgendwas Belastendes sagt. Warum soll man dann nicht dessen Handy zum Beispiel überwachen? Das ist eine zielgerichtete Überwachung aufgrund eines bestimmten Tatverdachts. Ich persönlich rechtsstaatlich überhaupt kein Problem mit. Das sollten wir tun. Das eigentliche Problem ist eben genau dieses Stichwort Massenüberwachung, der gerade kein Verdacht zugrunde liegt, wo einfach jeder im Prinzip ins Raster fallen kann. Und da in diese Kategorie fällt eben die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo die Verkehrsdaten von allen Menschen gespeichert werden oder eben die Internetüberwachung des BND, die ja eben gerade keine bestimmten Verdächtigen ins Ziel, äh ins Visier nimmt, sondern einfach jedermann. Und wie Katja gerade schon gesagt hat, ist das große Problem bei der Massenüberwachung, eben die berühmte Nadel in diesem gigantischen Heuhaufen zu finden. Und das scheint immer weniger zu gelingen. Sascha Lobo hat das am Beispiel der Attentäter von Paris mal im Spiegel genauer analysiert. Von denen waren einige sogar mit Haftbefehl gesucht. Andere standen zumindest auf Beobachtungslisten der Polizei. Es fehlte nicht an irgendwie Daten. Also es war einfach, Daten waren da. Es fehlte an Menschen, die die auswerten. Mit anderen Worten, wenn man wirklich sich um Sicherheit Gedanken macht, dann sollte man, wie sie gerade schon sagte, wegkommen von dieser Massenüberwachung, die im Wesentlichen eine Illusion von Sicherheit schafft. Man muss sich Gedanken machen, wo liegen denn die wirklichen Probleme, weswegen Ermittlungsbehörden im konkreten Fall versagt haben. Leider, gerade in Frankreich und Belgien gibt es ja diese Fälle des Versagens in Deutschland bislang jedenfalls deutlich weniger. Aber um auf diesen Anrufer zurückzukommen, wenn tatsächlich Attentate aufgrund von Geheimdienstinformationen verhindert werden konnten, dann scheint mir das sehr offensiv kommuniziert zu werden. Mir fällt allerdings nur ein Beispiel ein, das waren die sogenannten Sauerland-Bomber. Das waren ja Menschen, die in einer Garage chemische Stoffe gesammelt haben, mit denen sie dann möglicherweise Bomben bauen wollten. Und da wurde relativ offensiv kommuniziert. Ob das stimmt, weiß man nicht. Dass da ein Tipp eines ausländischen Geheimdienstes ausschlaggebend war. Ob das tatsächlich stimmt, wissen wir nicht. Aber das ist so der einzige Fall, den ich persönlich jedenfalls gerade vor Augen habe. Es mag ein paar andere geben. Aber es stimmt, glaube ich, nicht, dass solche Fahndungserfolge aufgrund von Geheimdienstinformationen unter der Decke gehalten werden. Ganz im Gegenteil. Wenn es denn tatsächlich mal Erfolge gibt, dann wird das sehr offensiv kommuniziert.
Teilweise werden auch versucht, ergebliche Erfolge zu kommunizieren, die gar keine waren. Wenn ich mich jetzt an das Jahr 2013 erinnere, direkt nach den Snowden-Enthüllungen stand ja der BND unter unglaublichen Druck, dass er das irgendwie vermittelt und erklärt. Und da wurde eine Pressekonferenz gegeben, da wurde gesagt, wir haben massenhaft Terroranschläge mithilfe dieser Daten der NSA in Deutschland verhindern können. Und in den darauffolgenden Monaten gab es eben eine größere Diskussion. Da wurde wieder nachgefragt, naja nennen sie das doch mal jetzt die konkreten Beispiele. Und da ist nichts von übergeblieben. Das heißt, es gab gar keine nachweisbaren Effekte, positiven Effekte dieser Überwachung. Was eben übrig geblieben ist, ist das, was der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss aufgeklärt hat, eben diese ganzen negativen Beispiele, dass massenweise Journalisten, NGOs, EU-Abgeordnete teilweise da ins Raster gefallen sind.
Ich meine, wenn man genau hinguckt, dann stellt man fest, die Sauerlandgruppe und die geplanten Attentate von denen, das ist das Beispiel, was von den Diensten permanent hochgehalten wird. Wenn es heißt, was waren denn die Erfolge aktuell, die Sauerlandgruppe und dann noch irgendwie diese Messerstecherin aus Hannover, Islamistin, junge Frau, ganz dramatisch. Das sind die beiden Beispiele, die du permanent präsentiert kriegst und andere gibt es nicht. Ich würde gerne noch widersprechen wollen zu dieser Geschichte, dass es bisher glücklicherweise keine Fälle gegeben hat, hier in Deutschland, wo Geheimdienste versagt haben, vielleicht nicht im Bereich große Terroranschläge, aber wenn wir jetzt mal kurz den Blick auf den Verfassungsschutz und auf den NSU lenken, würde ich sagen, da ist sehr großflächig versagt worden. Und selbst der Verfassungsschutz ist im Nachhinein noch mal wieder kräftig aufgerüstet worden, auch eher im Bereich Internetüberwachung und Massenüberwachung. Und das geht einfach total in die falsche Richtung. Wenn man dann als nächstes, und das gehört zu dem, was ich momentan viel mache, den Politikern und den Diensten genau zuhört, dann sagen die natürlich auf jeden Fall auch, na das, was wir machen hier, ist keine Massenüberwachung, das hörst du in den USA ganz genauso. Wir machen hier nur gezielte Überwachung. Ganz gezielt suchen wir nur nach Terroristen und dann noch ein bisschen nach organisierter Kriminalität und noch ein bisschen nach Waffenhandel. Aber das ist ganz gezielt und das ist keine Massenüberwachung. Aber dafür benutzen sie dann eben Millionen und Milliarden von Selektoren und sammeln Massen von Daten, versuchen uns aber zu verkaufen, dass das diese ungediebte Massenüberwachung vielleicht doch irgendwie nicht wäre.
Aber was ich mich zu sagen am Ende frage ist, es wird ja sozusagen nicht nur heute hier wurde das noch mal ganz klar dargelegt, sondern das kann man sich ja auch anlesen, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Also man kommt sozusagen nicht dran vorbei, dass Überwachung was Schlechtes ist, was Auswirkungen auf eine Gesellschaft hat, was auch Auswirkungen auf den Einzelnen haben kann. Was ich mich da frage ist, warum wird denn das trotzdem immer vorgeschlagen? Das kann ich mir bei BND konkret vorstellen. Das ist eine Behörde, die hat auch ein Budget, die hat auch Leute, die muss ihren Selbstzweck erhalten. Das ist ein Selbstwert, die nicht, wenn man sagt, was wir machen, das ist ganz toll, wir brauchen auch mehr Geld und dann ist Überwachung so super. Aber Politik zum Beispiel.
Das haben wir vorhin schon mal, diese Frage, warum machen die Politiker das alles mit? Und da kann man sich innen Politiker lang und breit angucken. Interessant ist ja auch immer, in dem Moment, wo die im Amt sind, sind die total scharfe Hunde. Und im Moment, wo sie dann nicht mehr im Amt sind, also nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal Gerd Baum, war früher Innenminister in Deutschland, ist jetzt ein wirklich engagierter Überwachungskritiker und da ist er nicht der einzige. Es gibt keine wirklich schlüssige Erklärung dafür, was ich ganz interessant fand, um vielleicht noch mal den Blick auch auf Snowden und die Enthüllungen zu lenken. Da gibt es ja ganz klare Hinweise dafür, dass die Geheimdienste, und jetzt kann man mir sagen, das ist irgendwie spinne, aber steht so in den Unterlagen, kann man nachlesen. Die sammeln ja aber auch Überwachungsergebnisse über eben genau die Politiker, um die gegebenenfalls damit erpressen zu können, damit die dann die Entscheidungen so treffen, wie die Dienste das wollen. Dazu gibt es für Deutschland bisher keinerlei Belege, jedenfalls sind mir keine bekannt. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Politiker, die sich letzten Endes oft fachlich vielleicht den Diensten auch unterlegen fühlen, erstens die Verantwortung nicht übernehmen wollen, wenn denn doch mal was passiert. Das heißt, wenn man ihnen genügend ausführlich schildert, wie schrecklich die Gefahren sind, dann ist das schon mal ein passendes Argument. Und wenn zweitens ihnen dann noch gesagt wird, pass auf, wenn du nicht genauso entscheidest, wie ich das gerne hätte, dann packe ich hier doch mal zum Beispiel das Strafverfahren wegen Körperverletzung auf den Tisch, was hier im Moment noch in einem Archiv vor sich hin schimmelt, was du gerne nicht in der Öffentlichkeit haben willst. Das wäre sozusagen nur ein Beispiel. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es davon noch mehr gibt. Ich glaube, die Dienste, die haben faktisch keine Kontrolle. Und die wollen auch nicht kontrolliert werden. Das heißt, die versuchen, sich die Politik auch vom Leib zu halten. Und die Politik ist oft auch ganz froh, wenn sie es nicht so genau weiß, wenn sie die Verantwortung nicht übernehmen muss. Das ist eine Win-Win-Situation für beide. Und die Demokratie fällt aber leider dabei hinten runter.
Und um noch mal auf die Struktur der Politik zu kommen, bei Überwachungsgesetzen ist ja auch die Argumentation, dass das nur vorübergehend. Die Sicherheitslage ist jetzt angespannt. Wir müssen jetzt was tun. Hinterher packen wir das alles wieder weg. Das Problem ist aber, es gibt keinen gesetzlichen Sicherheitsmechanismus, der quasi vorschreibt, nach einem Jahr oder nach zwei Jahren muss jetzt untersucht werden, wie der Anrufer auch eben angeregt hat. Also es muss dann offensiv kommuniziert werden, was sind die Erfolge, aber auch natürlich, was sind die Misserfolge, beispielsweise wo wurde offensichtlich Missbrauch betrieben. Und auf dieser Basis müssen dann die Politiker, sage ich mal, argumentieren, warum sie dieses Gesetz entweder weiter fortlaufen lassen wollen oder warum das eben eingesammelt oder angepasst werden muss. Und tatsächlich gab es mal so einen Prozess bei der europäischen Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. 2010 gab es eine Re-Evaluation der EU-Richtlinie. Da bin ich dann nach Brüssel gefahren mit einigen Aktivisten-Kollegen von AK Vorrat. Und wir haben monatelang vorher ein Shadow-Paper, also so ein Shadow-Report geschrieben, also ein Dokument, wo ganz viele unterschiedliche Fälle aus allen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten aufgelistet wurde, wo die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ganz konkret missbraucht wurde, um beispielsweise Journalisten zu überwachen. Oder wo beispielsweise die Polizistin wegen irgendeiner Beziehung dann mal in der Datenbank privat nachgeguckt hat. Und wir haben das dann eingereicht und sind dann zu der Sitzung gefahren. Und dann hat der Vertreter der Kommission gesagt, ja, Missbrauchsfälle sind uns nicht bekannt. Und neben mir die Vertreterin aus Polen hat ihre Hand gehoben, war total sauer, meinte so wie. Wir haben doch das Dokument eingereicht. Und er meinte, na ja, wir haben die Vertreter der EU-Mitgliedstaaten, die Regierung gefragt, ist Missbrauch bekannt? Und sie haben gesagt nein. Und da habe ich an der Stelle wirklich eine Frust geschoben. Ich war kurz davor hinzuschmeißen, mich nicht mehr zu engagieren. Und ich bin der Meinung, man muss einfach auch Bürgerrechtsorganisationen stärker einbinden und auch stärker hören, wenn es um Bedenken geht. Im Vorfeld und nicht im Nachhinein. Dann müssen wir auch nicht auf die Straße gehen.
Es bleibt noch einiges zu tun. Die Sendung ist leider gleich vorbei. Ich würde deswegen etwas in weiser Voraussicht machen, weil als wir letztes Jahr sozusagen über das Thema gesprochen haben, wussten wir nicht, dass wir uns dieses Jahr auch nochmal drüber unterhalten werden und sich gar nicht so viel geändert hat. Ich würde aber vermuten, nächstes Jahr haben wir wieder Gelegenheit. Und deswegen jetzt noch mal der Reihe nach die Frage an euch, worüber reden wir in einem Jahr?
Über das verabschiedete und in Kraft getretene BND-Gesetz, das vom Verfassungsschutz, vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert wurde. Ich glaube, das wird bis nächstes Jahr nicht vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert werden, sondern das wird noch zwei Jahre dauern, bis das im Gesetz kassiert wird.
Alles klar.
Ulf?
Ich möchte eine Hoffnung äußern. Im nächsten Jahr, um diese Zeit, befinden wir uns entweder gerade noch im Bundestagswahlkampf, der genaue Termin steht noch nicht fest, oder? Oder steht schon fest? Jedenfalls ist es die Zeit der Bundestagswahl. Ich hoffe, dass wir im Vorfeld dieser Wahl intensiver darüber diskutieren, welche Rolle der Schutz von Privatsphäre und der Schutz vor Überwachung im politischen System spielen. Und dass wir auch ganz gezielt dann die Bewerber und politische Ämter fragen, wie hältst du es mit der Privatsphäre?
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wann die Wahl ist, aber ich glaube, Ende September wird sie dann gewesen sein. Das heißt, wir werden uns langsam warmlaufen für den nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss.
Ich sitze ja auch im Beirat des Whistleblower-Netzwerks. Deshalb hoffe ich stark darauf, dass wir uns im nächsten Jahr über das quasi deutsche Pendant zu Edward Snowden unterhalten werden. Den BND-Mitarbeiter, der nochmal ganz andere Sachen ausgepackt hat, als Vorarbeit für den nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss.
Alles klar, darf ich auch gerne dabei. Also liebe BND-Mitarbeiter, wenn ihr diese Sendung gehört habt, wisst ihr jetzt, an wen ihr euch wenden könnt. Liebe Gäste, die hier wart, vielen Dank für die erhellenden und wenn manchmal auch ein bisschen frustrierenden Erkenntnisse und Erlebnisse aus der Diskussion um Überwachung. Ich habe noch eine kurze Sache zu sagen und zwar, falls ihr euch dafür interessiert, was ganz junge Menschen mit der Technik neu machen, könnt ihr am 16. Oktober zur Jugendhackt-Abschlussveranstaltung kommen. Diese in der Volksbühne ist also richtig viel Platz, da könnt ihr alle kommen. Und ansonsten bleibt noch zu sagen, nach uns kommt Flo Heiler, wird euch mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ihr könnt das gerne als Podcast hören und macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst sie nicht überwachen.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Bjatch!